presented today the joint work done with
lui
university and um
it's about performance simulation which
is
considered one of the most promising
applications for quantum computers
and this is identified as early as 40
years ago by fimin
and in particular we're going to focus
on
analog quantum simulation and normally
when people think of quantum stimulation
they typically think of digital
simulation which is
reproducing the dynamics under
hamiltonian age by a quantum circuit
in contrast analog simulation is the
task of
reproducing one quantum system h by
another
uh hamiltonian age soda with the hope
that each soda is more easily
accessible in the experiment and
also this idea of mapping between
hamiltonians is also a very fundamental
in the study of quantum complexity
theory since
it is basically the generalization of
mapping between
constrained satisfaction now in 2012
uh sarah consoler has argued that this
type of analog simulation can be more
robust against errors
than digital simulation with circuits
because
the areas that you that you encounter in
these situations can be sort of treated
as an effective temperature
uh which in any realistic physical
system you want to simulate
will also be at a finite temperature uh
and
and because of that they're more
promising to implement on near-term
quantum devices and indeed there has
been a lot of remarkable
technological progress in this direction
uh i'll give you a couple examples
uh so some of you may have heard about
many body localization and time crystals
so these are actually originally
hypothetical phenomena
proposed by some physicists and there's
actually been a lot of debates in the
community about what whether these are
real effects or simply artifacts from
finite size numerical simulations
and recently in a series of beautiful
experiments uh
in uh mostly led by christopher uh some
of some of it led by
chris montzero group in maryland using
tribe ions
they were able to show that using 55
ions
there's a lot of strong experimental
evidence that these effects
are are real and they do exist uh in
in in in our world and as another
example
uh there also has been a really
cool developments in using systems of
neutral atoms in rearrangeable optical
tweezers to probe quantum phase
transitions and and recently
a coherent quantum phase transition has
been observed in a system as large as
250 atoms which is almost an order
magnitude larger than the
state-of-the-art
digital quantum computer analog
simulators have also been proposed to
address problems in chemistry
for example using fermionic atoms in
optical lattices
and there has also been some progress
using superconductors to simulate uh
vibrational spectra in molecules like
ozone and water
so these are all very nice experimental
you know progress which i
hope helped motivate you know why we
care about analog stimulation uh
and there but besides the experiments
there also have been some recently uh
nice uh uh progress in the theory of
analog simulation
uh specifically it has been found by uh
qubit montenarro and fidoc
in 2017 that there are actually some
simple families of hamiltonians that are
universal
in the sense that they can stimulate all
other hamiltonians
so this means that it's a system as
simple as say a 2d square lattice of
cubist with say tunable heisenberg type
interaction you can use that to simulate
something as complex as the long-range
interacting
antibody localized system or complex
molecular hamiltonian
or even the syk model with auto
interactions
which is believed to model certain
aspects of black holes
now this is nice because
experimentalists often only have limited
access to certain types of interactions
and geometry in an actual quantum device
so if you can implement these universal
systems uh in the experiment you can
principally simulate anything you want
well this result is very nice but in
reality
uh we also care about the actual
resources required using the simulators
in practice so in the analysis of uh
this 2017 paper by cuba montanaro and
tidoc they found that if you have a
target hamiltonian that is say two
dimensional
you can efficiently you can indeed
efficiently simulate them on a 2d
universal system and by efficiency here
i mean that
the the number of particles required in
the simulator as well as all the
interaction energy
aka the coupling strength between
particles they only grow polynomially as
the
original system says
on the other hand if you have a system a
target system that is say 2d
a three-dimensional or worse uh all
connected
uh the analysis shown in this 2017 paper
uh showed that their energy
interaction energy required uh to
simulate them with a 2d system
scales exponentially so we call these
systems which are
you know which may require exponential
resource in some cases
as weakly universal
so so in my result with dory we were
happily able to show that there are in
fact
some very simple hamiltonians that are
strongly universal
in the sense that in addition to being
at least weekly weekly universal
all the resources required for
simulation uh
only scale polynomially for in the
system size uh as well as all the
target uh precision parameters uh given
so this is in contrast to the
exponential resource uh
you know required for some target
hamiltonians under weak universality
well concretely this means that we are
we're able to take any hamiltonians 3d
or tr it doesn't matter
in fact we were able to show that you
know as long as the hamiltonian can be
efficiently simulated by a circuit
which we call a in the level we can
actually map them to
efficiently to a 2d spring lattice model
or even a
1d chain of 8 dimensional particles
and so both both of these families that
i mentioned 2d and 1d are
are strongly universal in the sense that
they described they can
all the resources are polynomial and
this works for
any target hamiltonian that you can
simulate with a circuit efficiently
so our result actually sort of
established a
complexity equivalence between analog
and digital quantum simulation
since we have shown that a quantum
system can be efficiently simulated by a
circuit
if and only if it has a efficient analog
simulation
and this is actually implies that analog
quantum simulation is perhaps uh
realistic for more general systems than
well
what was previously thought
now for the rest of my talk i will uh
first uh you know
define uh what i mean by hamiltonian
simulation and universality more
precisely
and then i'll review uh the previous
results about universal hamiltonians
and also i'll give you a a more
precise uh formulation of our results uh
in how we constructed this
strongly universal hamiltonian
so let's start by rigorously define what
we mean by uh
hamiltonian simulation uh and what we
did is we actually adopted a well
motivated definition
uh i think initially developed by
bravian hastings uh but later refined by
uh and the definition here
is that if you we say that h tilde the
hamiltonian simulates uh the hamiltonian
h
if the following is true so if you look
at all the
spectrum of your target hamiltonian age
and if they are reproduced as the low
energy spectrum of your simulator h
chorda with some encoding uh uh we told
that that sort of preserves locality of
observables and we say it show that
simulates h
uh more precisely this means that the
operator uh
h uh tilde when it's restricted to the
eigenstates below some kind of
delta uh that operator is epsilon close
to the
encoded uh original hamiltonian h in the
operator
sense and we also want the encoding
vitilla to be approximately local in the
sense that they are
the isometry operator utoda is ada close
to the tensor product decomposition that
acts independently on
the original particles and this locality
is sort of important for preserving the
locality of
observables and noise processes which is
part of the argument why we consider
analog simulations to be more robust
in the experiment
and i i want to then start for my next
definition i will define universality
and and we will define it in the context
of families of hamiltonians which are
our two local so so
we write basically any such two local
hamiltonian in the following form
uh you have a h which is written as a
sum over some of the edges of the
interaction graph
and the we factor j i j we call that the
interaction energy
and and h hat is the operator that acts
on the side i and j
but in principle this h hat could change
between the different pairs of size so
we also inserted this
side dependent parameter phi ij
and and so the idea of weak
universality is that you can take any n
particle reasonable hamiltonian
uh if you can map it to a from uh uh
hamiltonian h
from the family uh using the definition
earlier
uh that you know saying that it should
stimulate h then we say that this family
of hamiltonian
is weakly universal and
and we say that the family is strongly
universal if it is both weakly universal
and also that the
hamiltonian that you chose from the
family is show that uh you know all the
energy
and the number of particles only uh only
scale polynomially in the system size n
as well as all the precision parameters
so what i mean by reasonable here is
sort of
uh uh you know you know a little bit you
know
vague but i will kind of tell you what i
mean so you know in the earlier work on
universal hamiltonians uh the reasonable
really just only
refers to uh sort of uh local
hamiltonians with the locality is
constant
uh but if but we as we kind of develop
our result
we find that actually this you know a
lot more hamiltonians are more
i can't be considered reasonable so so
the largest you know reasonable
uh families of hamiltonian that you want
to simulate are the ones that you can
simulate with a column circuit
and that that's what we call circuit
stimulable and more precisely we say
that a hamiltonian h is circuit
simulable if uh
there's a quantum circuit uh composed of
you know say one or two qubit
like uh universal gates uh and if the
size
only scales as long as uh the size of
the circuit scale is only polynomially
in the system size
uh the time as well as the precision
parameter
and able to approximate the evolution of
the hamiltonian
uh for time t then we say that this
h is circuit symbol
okay so now i sort of define what
universality means i will also define
translational invariance because that's
actually kind of a nice property to have
especially when we try to implement
these them in the experiment
so there's two notions of translation
invariants uh semia
and fu so we say that a family of
hamiltonian is semi-translational
invariant if all the
uh or the two particle operators
between every pair of size that we have
on the interaction graph is the same
so for example in uh the one i have
shown here
the the example hamiltonian showdown
here is uh semi-translational invariant
because all the
interaction is sort of of x x form even
though the coefficient might be
different
uh if we impose a stronger constraint
that not only the operators are the same
but also the interaction energy is the
same then we say that the family is
fully translationally invariant
and i know that here we only talked
about the the
translational invariance of the really
the hamiltonian operators
we're not saying anything about the
underlying interaction graph
but typically we consider sort of an
interaction graph that is sort of
regular like a lattice
uh for this really definition to to make
sense
okay so now i have defined uh given all
the uh
the definitions uh so i can now describe
our
results in more detail uh so i will
start by
you know telling you a bit more about
the previous results on universality
uh so so in this earlier result they
took basically any local hamiltonian it
could be a s5k model
and they apply a bunch of protective
gadgets to them so for example you can
take a complicated interaction graph and
reduce the graph degree using something
called the
port gadget and it was also found later
that you can make the gadget
fit on the two-dimensional lattice so
doing so
allows you to map the original target
hamiltonian h to a 2d spin lattice model
as shown in the work by
a pedagogue in montenarro and these
models are
semi-translation invariant because uh
all the interaction operator between
pairs of sites are the same
in this case they can choose them to be
just heisenberg sort of type interaction
uh about the interaction energy jij very
spatially
now why are these hamiltonians only
weakening universal
in the original construction well that's
because if you have a dense interaction
graph like the syk model you need to
apply degree reduction
many times to to map it to a finite
dimensional lattice
where the interaction graph has finite
degree
and in general you would need log n
number of rounds of perturbative gadgets
and after each round of the gadget
application the
the interaction energy should blow up
polynomially
and after you know log n number of
rounds you end up with exponential
overhead
energy and this is why
in the original 2017 paper they were
only able to show that these
2d spin loudest models were weakly
universal
but in our result we were able to show
that you know using better encodings
these very same
spin lapse models into the are implied
strongly universal
and we took it a step further and showed
that you know a very simple 1d
hamiltonian uh where we only use nearest
neighboring interaction on the line
where the particles are have you know
eight levels eight dimensions
uh that hamiltonian is also uh
strongly universal and here the
interaction
uh between the nearest neighbor enforces
sort of transition rules between
configurations in sort of a kind of a
circuit computation
so there is sort of no translation in
variance of any sense in this case
and as i said both families are
are strongly universal and they can
efficiently simulate not only
just local hamiltonians but any circuit
simulable hamiltonians
i will now compare our result to the
previous result as
of not just the original 2017 paper but
also
uh some follow-up work in this following
table
so after the initial week universality
results in 2017
uh uh uh others have also been able to
show that uh
you know a bunch of other families uh in
both 2d and 1d
and actually possessing full
translational invariants are also
universal in the weak sense
because uh you know for all of them the
interaction energy
in their construction scales
exponentially in the general case and in
some cases the particle number also
scales exponentially
and in contrast our results only require
polynomial energy
as well as well as a particle number and
and we were able to do this in both just
a 2d
sort of square lattice type geometry as
well as a 1d
a near stapler line geometry
and i will make a couple remarks here so
first i will note that
our results are somewhat tight because
uh
in an earlier work uh that i that i did
with reading uh in 2018
we showed that general simulation uh of
hamiltonians with only
sort of a constant interaction energy
and degree is impossible
so this basically means that it's
unlikely that we're able to lower
the interaction energy uh from
polynomial to anything below i mean
i mean i guess there is possible room
for a logarithmic energy but certainly
we cannot do it with constant energy
and secondly i will note that uh the
notion of strong universality
uh is a strict subset of weak
universality
and this is because there are weakly
universal families like these two
which cannot be made shown in universal
and this can be seen by a sort of an
information theoretical argument
uh because of the fact that you know
these this families have
very strict form of translation variants
where the only free parameter is the
number of particles
okay so i would now uh for the for the
last part of my talk i would describe
sort of just the basic key ideas
behind how we are able to construct our
results
so the first idea is developing a method
to perform the reduction of interaction
graphs in a non-predictive way
because remember from earlier if you do
degree reduction with
just protective gadgets you would
generally require
exponential energy if you're you know if
your
starting degree is say order n
[Music]
another fact that i haven't that i
mentioned just earlier is that you know
we cannot hope to do degree reduction
with only constant interaction energy
due to this impossibility result uh
nevertheless uh we developed a way to
perform degree reduction
uh with only with only polynomial
interaction energy and this is done by
the circuits
which i will explain now um
so the idea is to take any target
hamiltonian which can be auto
interacting
doesn't matter i have written it down
here as a decomposition into eigenstates
but i don't need to know them explicitly
we can then consider the quantum phase
estimation circuit
running on the unitary e to the ih tau
so what this circuit does is that it
takes any eigenstates
of of h as input and and write down the
energy eigenvalue
as a b string uh on some ancilla
so in the context of circuits uh you
know degree reduction is much easier to
achieve than
i think in the hamiltonian context
because we can use enceladus and swap
gates
and that's why you know we map the
hamiltonian into a circuit and then we
do the
reduction and what i mean by that is uh
if you could take your circuit with some
you know unitary acting uh
you know pairs of cubits uh and we want
to reduce the degree of each qubit which
in
the context of circuits just correspond
to how many gates are applied to them
and by simply adding ancillary gates uh
or fresh and silicates in fact after
every gate and then swapping
the quantum state of the the cubits that
were acted onto the to the french
cylinder in this way we can basically
see that
you know that we are able to reduce the
degree of the
the qubits a and b since they are never
touched afterwards uh after the swap
gates
so without much trouble as you can see
we have reduced you know
the degree uh very simply using insulin
swap
once you converted the hamiltonian to a
circuit
we can also make this uh construction
more sophisticated and create a circuit
that's embeddable in two dimension in a
spatially sparse way and then applying
sort of something
something called the ketav circuit to
hamiltonian mapping
allows us to transform this phase
estimation circuit after the degree
reduction step
to a 2d hamiltonian whose ground states
encode the circuit computational history
but this trick on its own is not enough
because we still need to be able to
distinguish the eigenvalues between
different eigenstates
and and this can be done by a second
idea which is
uh making use of the fact that you know
in the phase estimation circuit the
energy is written down
as a b string on the ancillary at one
point
so then by adding uh the energy penalty
term to the uh uh to the hamiltonian bit
by bit
um so so once you have your energy
written down as a b string
you can simply you know add add a
penalty to uh to that particular bit
you know uh you know well and and also
you know uh
time it so that you know it only applies
when the uh
when the uh circuit has run to the point
where the
energy is written down then you know
using this very simple energy penalty
uh term you can basically recover all
the
eigenvalue structure of the original
hamiltonian
so using this sort of two key ideas uh
we're able to basically take any circuit
simulable hamiltonian
you know which you know as long as you
have an efficient circuit for the each
of the ihc
you can then using very standard
techniques like you know cauterization
et cetera and map it to a phase
estimation circuit using only nearest
neighbor gates
in 1d and then you can use sort of this
non-perturbative
degree reduction uh and the energy
penalty to
you know map the circuit to a 2d
spatially sparse circuit and then
that could be mapped to a 2d spatially
sparse hamiltonian
which then using you know additional
ideas
like you know these gadgets that are
embeddable in two dimensions uh we can
map it to a two-dimensional
semi-translationally variant hamiltonian
on a say a square lattice
and for the 1d construction uh it's sort
of you know very similar
we can take the the phase estimation
circuit uh
in 1d and then we can sort of modify the
the 1d clock hamiltonian construction
that was used to prove qma completeness
of 1d hamiltonians in you know in papers
like
uh the 27 2007 paper uh by dorit and
others as well as a more refined
construction
later by uh hellgren and narayana swami
and and you can actually you know use
only eight dimensional particles in one
d
to sort of uh map this circuit to a
hamiltonian
uh where uh you know all the low energy
states reproduces the original
target hamiltonian's eigenstates
so that's basically the the outline of
the structure of our
our our construction and that's what
enabled us to get this nice strong
universal results
uh i would then end my talk now with uh
a summary
uh of uh what what we've done we have
established that the strongly universal
uh analog quantum simulation is possible
uh
not only for you know local hamiltonians
but actually for any circuit single
stimulable hamiltonians
and this can be done as i said earlier
that you know you can
do it with something as simple as well
1d 2d
kind of lattice models using only
polynomial number of particles and
interaction energy
and and we believe that you know this
result is somewhat tight
uh at least in the asymptotic sense
because uh there's no way to lower the
interaction energy to constant
uh by an earlier impossibility result
and uh and our result has to establish
sort of this equivalence between
the efficient being able to do efficient
circuit simulation and being able to do
efficient analog simulation
and really the takeaway message is that
you know i i i
think that you know analog quantum
simulation you know really is
more relevant relevant for many more
systems than what was maybe previously
thought
and there are also some very uh i think
interesting open questions that we would
like to pursue uh
in particular uh you know we're
interested in
to to understand if we can improve the
translation and variance properties of
our construction
and potentially extend them to to
fermion-based simulators
uh and furthermore in our work we did
not really use the most efficient
construction
and really chose the methods and the
most straightforward for provable
results
so there's a lot of room for improvement
to to bring the overhead
uh down to an experimentally relevant
regime
and in particular we were wondering if
there's a way to develop sort of the uh
a kind of a way to do degree reduction
locally uh beyond just sort of this uh
hamiltonian two circuit to hamiltonian
idea that we have
and lastly we want to develop a better
theory
of noise in these analog simulations
because
most of our current understanding is
based on sort of heuristic arguments
and folklore and in conclusion
i hope i have convinced you that the
future of analog quantum simulation is
bright
uh and i invite all of you to to try to
work on these questions with us and i'm
happy to take any questions
from the audience hey thank you very
much leo
[Applause]
um i have a question leo um so
so um you know that's a that's a very
nice result but
um there's a different way one could ask
the same
the same questions in terms of saying
well
how would you program using hamiltonians
and so if you look at it from that
viewpoint then
and what you're saying is well you
program using
hamiltonians by first converting to
circuits and then programming the
circuits
but could you look inside your results
and say now now that you have your
result
could you directly program in terms of
hamiltonians and what would those
primitives look like
yeah that's sort of what i'm kind of
alluding to here uh because you know i
think that
it is unsatisfying to to kind of go
through a circus
in order to make our result work uh uh
and i i agree that you know you know you
know now that we know that it is
possible to do this sort of degree
reduction to
do this efficient mapping at least in
principle there are probably smarter
ways to do it
and and i think that you know especially
often what happens is that you know if
you have a particular hamiltonian in
mind
and you have a particularly experimental
system in mind there's often you know
efficient ways to map between them
uh you know from a more you know like
you know
like quantum optics point of view for
example like you know there are tricks
one can play
uh uh to to engineer specific kind of
type of interactions
uh uh so so so that is something that we
are thinking about um
but but yeah uh we don't have any you
know concrete results yet but i
i do believe that you know there's
probably a way to do this without going
through circuits
following up on umesh's question it also
occurs to me that the sense of time
is different between the original
hamiltonian and the final one
because in the final one time is the
time
through the circuit elements and that
notion of time is enforced by the clock
that's used to represent the
sequence of gate operations um and so
it becomes non-linear with respect to
the original time am i correct about
this
and uh in some way yes but i think
there's a distinction between so the the
time that's in the circuit uh
you know really you know is
uh applicable to sort of the precision
of the
sort of the the eigenvalues that you
want to like so basically
the time that you use in this like
virtual circuit that you use in this
construction
really is related to how precise you
want your final target
final hamiltonian to be in terms of the
eigenvalue how close they are to the
original eigenvalues
but that is also important if you want
to say simulate
the original hamiltonian to some some
time
uh you know because you know you need
your eigenvalues to be precise if you
want to reproduce
the food dynamics to some given time
but they are not you know directly
related but they are related in this
sort of
roundabout way if you if you know if
that makes sense
yeah i appreciate the roundabout
connection but
if i were just speaking as an
experimentalist for
original system often experimentalists
want to measure some observable as a
function of time
and then if you go through the circuit
representation you'd have to do
something else to get the same
observable as a function of time because
now
the increase in time will be only an
increase in the first part of the phase
estimation circuit
and you still have to do the sequencing
through your four-year transform et
cetera et cetera
i think that you know it's possible that
you know often in the experiment you
don't necessarily also care about you
know reproducing the food spectrum
precisely there there's probably you
know often when you measure things in
experiment
you maybe only care about you know
certain properties that are
robust that are maybe universal uh that
i mean i'm using universal here in a
different sense
like more condensed matter theory
perspective but but what i'm saying is
that you know
it's possible that you don't actually
need to have a very precise
uh you know uh error in the eigenvalue
mapping
to get a good you know to simulate long
long time kind of you know observables
because maybe the corresponding low
energy physics that
that is robust that's fair
thank you other questions
if not i have one more
i have a question about um
is there like an easy tuition for the
possibility of
uh constant strength
degree reduction uh yes yes so
uh so basically what we did uh you know
in in the earlier work is that we were
able to find some contrary example
that we can construct uh where basically
uh uh the idea is that you know we
constructed
some hamiltonians which are auto
interacting so they have a dense
interaction graph
and and we're able to make it make it so
that the ground state is sort of this
highly entangled state that basically
between any pair is a particle there is
sort of some you know non-trivial
uh entanglement uh and also we make the
diagram say gap now you may
some of you may know that you know a gap
hamiltonian
uh in sort of a like you know
finite dimensional lattice for example
have unnecessarily have sort of this
exponential decay of correlation
so basically that means that if you map
that hamiltonian that's dense to a
finite dimensional lattice
for example uh you cannot reproduce sort
of this
uh you know strong correlation between
every pairs of particles because
necessarily there exists
particles that are far apart once you
map it to the finite dimensional lattice
does that does that
okay
yeah so i have a question so you're
measuring your the cost of the
stimulation by the blow up and the
coefficients
uh what's your cost in terms of the
increase in number of particles
and is there a room is that polynomial
that is also polynomial yeah like
everything
you know uh basically the spectral norm
of the simulator the whole operator is
polynomial so
it's uh the other particles like the
number of particles polynomial the
interaction energy
of every term is polynomial so is there
hope of
decreasing that or is there an
impossibility results related
to that so could you potentially get o
one blow up
in the number of particles uh
i guess we haven't ruled that out yet uh
i guess maybe you know there is no
i don't think necessarily we can rule
that out i mean you know it's very
possible that
only a linear scaling
is necessary for the number of particles
in the simulator but
we haven't really studied that
particular uh direction i guess
the last two questions were really very
much along the same lines is
the no fast forwarding theorem that
applies for
digital quantum simulation i'm i'm
curious if you
have thought about relating that because
for example
maybe you'd like to be able to fast
forward some simulations also
and if you can fast forward in the
analog simulation because you know
the mean field hamiltonian surely you
should be able to fast forward your
simulation as well
yeah that's a very good question yeah
that is an idea we i would thought about
like you know i think that
uh the connection that that we that we
had in mind is that i think certain
fast-forward about hamiltonians
uh have probably you know can be
you know uh simulated more easily like
for example they could even
be simulated efficiently by a fully
translational invariant one
but i think the no fast forwarding
essentially
you know we're trying to basically prove
that there's no way to have a strong
universal hamiltonian with full
translational invariance and i think we
might need to rely on those fast
forwarding
i would like to reverse and i would also
like to see
somebody postulate a no squashable
theorem
so like the last two questions we're
asking can't reduce space
as well and then for you to come up with
some squashable simulations because you
know something
extra about the system that's a very
cool quest that is a very cool direction
yeah
thanks for that suggestion yeah that's
very cool
other questions we still have a few
minutes i think
because the schedule officially said uh
1
15. i do have another question if nobody
else does
i think there are some questions in the
q a oh good thank you
okay uh forgive me for not seeing those
okay so um
your definition of what it means for a
hamiltonian to simulate another involved
locality
of encoding isometry
your definition of what it means for a
hamiltonian to simulate
another involved locality of the
encoding isometry
how do i see that that's true when you
plug things into the clock construction
yeah that's a very good question so we
that's uh that's kind of you know
uh one of the things that we have to
deal with to to make sure that you know
you satisfy this local
uh uh like this locality
uh and the idea is basically uh
uh there's sort of twofold uh sort of
you know first of all we
we uh we sort of you know uncom we have
the circuit that runs the
quantum phase estimation uh and we
uh we actually uncomputed so that you
know we get back the original
uh uh eigen states uh where you know
they're not alone they're not really
entangled with all the clock degrees of
freedom and then we also idle it
uh for a long time after the
uncomputation uh so that basically
you know the the history state of this
circuit is essentially
just the original state uh you know
weakly entangled with some clock qubits
and and uh and and
and and and basically and in the i don't
mean part crucially we do not move the
state of the particles around
in the lattice so basically you know
there's a long
like you know part of the history where
the eigenstates
sit basically locally on some set of the
particles and
and and you know because of the fact
that you know
uh they're only weakly entangled with
the rest you know this locality
condition in the definition is satisfied
approximately
i hope that answers the question if not
i can
elaborate more
okay uh another one could you give an
example
of a strongly universal experimental
analog
hamiltonian system uh yeah so i think
for example
the ibm device uh implements essentially
the x
uh the xy interaction on a on a 2d
lattice and that is an example of a
strong universe universal
hamiltonian and i'm sure that
you know many systems like in like like
uh code atoms uh ions uh
uh i mean i think they don't necessarily
i mean stuff
i mean in ions i think also the xy
interaction comes for free
but i think you know you can use
techniques like
you know uh uh like dynamical
uh uh like kind of uh
decoupling to kind of well like
dynamical chemical engineering to sort
of you know use poses to
effectively shape uh turn like
eigen-type interaction for example
into an x-y or or maybe even heisenberg
um so i i mean so the only thing that i
think that i that i know of that comes
you know naturally is uh as xy i think
is the ibm device but
but but then again i think actually uh a
lot of hamiltonians
beyond the heisenberg and the xy are are
are
strongly universal in fact we showed
that uh this is actually based on the
work with qubit montenegra they were
able to show that you know basically
most cubic cube could be interaction
except for basically almost a major zero
set
uh is uh it's like strongly universal
but the mapping is sort of non-trivial
uh that's probably the hardest part
also isn't the overhead non-trivial so
you need a very very very big
ibm quantum computer to be universal
yeah i mean yes
uh all of the overheads is not trivial
currently they're polynomial
in principle but they are just you know
end to the 20 or something like that uh
but i'm i i believe that all of these
constructions can be
improved much much further right
leo i i now i now feel that
um i'm not really sure about what your
what your
notion of locality was can you just go
over that briefly uh
so uh yeah so
my notion of locality here uh which is
adopted
from like you know the definition from
the 2017
paper is basically you know the the
eigenstates
their eigenstates are of the original
hamiltonian and their eigenstates of the
the hamiltonian age yoda and they're
mapped by this isometry
metoda and and i say that you know the
the map that this this mapping this
encoding is local if vtoda
can be approximately decomposed into a
tensor product
uh that acts independently on the
original
each of the original particle so uh
so so it's not exact uh
you know so that's why you know you
could allow sort of weak uh
nintendo between the the map particle
with the the clock to bits for example
um and you want that uh
for the lower part of the spectrum
there's only yeah this is this is only
necessary for the lower part like the
the other
the part of the spectrum of h2 that that
simulates the the spectrum of h
good image are you happy yeah yeah great
thanks
of course you're always happy so we can
move on
to another uh q a are there known
examples of non-circuit simulable
hamiltonians
uh i think like you know if you have a
hamiltonian that is
like literally a random commission
operator
in you know this exponential size silver
space that's probably not similar though
just because the complexity of
describing it is
exponential that's like a very trivial
example that i can come up with
on the spot um but
other than that i'm i'm not sure i mean
maybe
uh most of the hamiltonians that want to
encounter in nature i think are are
circumstantial i think
that's a good answer um let me take
privilege as chair to ask one last
question which i i'm burning to ask
which is
uh you're constructing uh really just
uh shows you can do a hamiltonian
simulation of a particular class of
phase estimation circuits
but though that phase estimation circuit
could be very very
um universal it could for example be
singular value transforms
signal processing it could actually be
not doing
a hamiltonian simulation so
so you're just showing in many ways if i
understand right that
you can efficiently do um
analog simulations of lots of digital
quantum circuits
yes so how about
how about a universal digital uh
universal quantum analog
machine since you can use singular value
transforms
that is a very tempting idea but i i
will say maybe that
you know one caveat is that you know in
this digital
circuit that you know really correspond
to actual algorithms you want to run
uh you do care about the fidelity of the
final state
uh whereas in stimulation we don't
necessarily care about you know preserve
having other states being exactly
reproduced to some epsilon you know
all we care about are you know local
observables and
even if there's some finite temperature
that's okay so
i think yes in principle you can
implement those uh you know quantum
singular value transformer because you
know these algorithms as an analog
simulator
but you might get a result that's not
what you wanted uh
it's when you measure it at least ah but
most of these digital circuits have
digital outputs
and if you're doing something that's
strongly distinguishable like uh
classification
or in qsvt sometimes just that one qubit
is the most important single qubit so
maybe it's fine
for your construction i see yeah that's
true yeah maybe there's a way to
yeah you know use leverage the the
robustness of this analog simulation to
to implement some of these algorithms
yeah i mean that would be very cool
i i think i need to think about it more
wow and then you can write a paper
that's about the grand unification of
everything quantum
okay uh let's thank leo so for a
beautiful talk
thank you
and next up we have zifka uh
yes yes you said hello okay
hey go ahead and share your screen
zipka is from the weizmann institute of
science and we'll